dieses mal hat alles zu 100 geklappt
nichts ging schief als die falcon heavy
um 18 35 ortszeit in florida vom longs
komplex 39 am kennedy space center
abbruch es war der erste kommerzielle
flug der falcons und er brachte den
satelliten absatz 6 in eine hohe
umlaufbahn für geostationäre satelliten
in rund 36.000 kilometern höhe
es war extrem spannend klicks um science
fiction die ele mars chroniken hier gibt
es täglich spannende science videos
abonnieren den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen es geht weiter space ex geht
seinen weg unbeirrbar das ist wirklich
absolut beeindruckend mittelfeld haben
sie aktuell die größte rakete der welt
rund 45 jahre nach dem flug der bis
heute noch größten rakete der menschheit
der saturn 5 startet ein neues monstrum
zum ersten mal nicht zum test sondern
mit einer kommerziellen nutzlast und
keine rakete kann so viel nutzlast
aktuell transportieren
je nach ort kann sind bis zu 63,8 tonnen
last in den weltraum bringen dass es
immens bei der falken ein sind es 22,8
also nur ein drittel dabei ist die
falcon heavy eigentlich eine umgebaute
feld hinein oder anders gesagt die erste
stufe der ferien heavy ist eine
umgebaute erste stufe der falken ein wie
bei der felgen sind neun merlin eines
der triebwerke an bord die jeweils 8 145
kilo newton start schub leisten dazu
kommen 2 booster mit denselben
spezifikationen zusammen leisten sie
unglaubliche 22,8 minuten durch die hohe
zahl an triebwerken können sogar welche
ausfallen so dass die mission dann nicht
einmal gefährdet wäre die zweite stufe
dagegen entspricht einer etwas
verlängertem zweiten stufe der verein
mit einem umgebauten berlin ans die
triebwerke mit 617 kilonewton schub es
kann 353 sekunden gezündet werden und
auch die fracht ist rekordverdächtig
absatz 6 a
er ist der fortschrittlichste
kommerzielle kommunikation verlief der
jemals von lockheed martin gebaut wurde
seine solarzellen sind
30 prozent leichter und 50
wirkungsvoller als bisher von lockheed
verbaut der start erfolgte an einem
historischen ort von der apollo
startrampe launchpad 39a in ted kennedy
von hier aus starteten alle apollo flüge
inklusive der legendären apollo 11 ihnen
mast spacex hat die startrampe für 20
jahre von der nasa ging von hier aus
wird auch der erste bemannte flug einer
felken rakete mit einer dragon kapsel im
juli abheben
beim start der fälle wie verlief dieses
mal alles wie am schnürchen werden beim
ersten start die landung der chor also
des zentralen element nicht gelang
landes auch dieses mal der chor perfekt
wobei die kamera dabei wieder ausziehen
und die booster die lieferten davor ein
absolut beeindruckendes bild das ist
wirklich absolut sagenhaft und damit
können alle drei elemente der ersten
stufe der lkw wieder verwendet werden
und das senkt die kosten der staat
massiv 90 millionen dollar kostet
anstatt auf diese weise die nasa
arbeitet zurzeit an einem konkurrenz
start system wobei konkurrenz kann man
schon nicht mehr sagen der staat einer
sts rakete der nasa sts steht für space
transportation system der soll rund eine
milliarde dollar kosten absurd hohe
kosten schon wird über das scheitern des
projektes gemutmaßt es bleibt spannend
weltraum auf züge der weg nach oben auf
eine etwas andere art draufklicken
anschauen und raumzeit block der zukunft
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran